This is one family's experience in a
string says it's, it's quite different,
different people.
But what you should realize is that
this is one of 300 million such stories.
The stories may be different,
but there's 300 million of them.
That's what the Chinese government is
now saying that the one child policy has
averted 300 million births in China,
that the population,
instead of being 1.3 billion
now would be 1.6 billion. And
that 300 million people is the total
population of the United States.
So China has as, as they perceive
it as they claim, averted,
putting another United States
worth of population into the world.
And that's the significance of,
of spending two full lectures on China.
And we could of course spend a lot more,
is that China's just so big that
everything that happens there has these
tremendous,
uh,
significances both on an
individual personal level
for each individual or family
that experiences it could
also on the global level,
one out of every five human beings
lives in China. So it is very big.
Um,
we'll talk in a later lecture
explicitly about the one child policy.
But there's information I have to give
you today to understand what it's about.
But let me just say now that the
Chinese government has of course,
well aware of the human and human rights
sacrifices of the individual people
and, but they argued that the
benefits outweigh the suffering.
And so just to give you a little hint of,
of the way the government
thinks about it and,
and many other people in China that the
great economic boom that China has had a
most economists now around
the world are attributed, uh,
the kickoff of that to the reduction
in fertility that they don't,
they didn't have to cope with so many
children and that's the cause of their
economy taking off. So, uh,
they perceive that the one child policy
has allowed China to merge from this,
you know, grinding poverty that they
were in and become a modern, uh,
we start to become a modern nation
in the world. Another story,
another data set that I just recently
came across was had to do with carbon
emissions that uh,
three at at,
at a world average of,
of carbon usage,
which is probably below
what China's actually using,
a 300 extra million people
would have produced 1.5 billion.
That's billion with a B billion
tons of co two each year.
And that's more than the total CO2
production of an industrial giant like
Germany. So if you're looking at this
issue from an environmental point of view,
the reduction of people there, their
environmental impact, it makes again,
a huge difference. And uh,
the Chinese for instance,
feel that because of the
one child policy alone,
they have done more than any other
country to ameliorate the environmental
crisis. Okay. That's just
a hint of very difficult,
uh, things. How do you weigh, uh, the,
the story of a family and
300 million families like,
like you've just heard against
the sort of macro issues and it,
it is not easy.
So the question I want to set up today,
which is to go backwards,
is
this kind of policy happens only in China.
This kind of enormous population
as the Chinese proceeded,
overpopulation happens in China really?
And in India in terms of massive stuff.
And we've,
we've talked a little
about India and South Asia,
but the question is what's
special about China?
Why did this happen in China? Why did, uh,
as they perceive it,
population got so out of control that
the government felt that they had to
introduce such a draconian policy
is there's such a stringent, uh,
kind of policy.
And the flip side of that coin
is why has China just now,
uh,
digging out from the abject poverty that,
that the people were in when a Europe
and America dug out 200 years ago?
England started, but all
of Europe and America, uh,
went through this phase 200
years ago. And, and why,
why not China? Of course,
this is a, is a very,
very hotly contested
issue among historians.
And the basic setup of the story is that
in about 1800 when morphis was writing,
uh, China was very powerful, very strong,
very rich country and,
and the West was,
was beginning to be that way.
The industrial revolution
with just starting in England.
And you would have seen
enormous differences between
China and say England or
Europe in 1800,
but you would not have been able to
predict which model was going to take over
the world, which country was going to
become bigger and stronger in the future.
China was a very impressive plus
impressive place in 1800 and Europe was
beginning to be a very
impressive place in 1800.
And then I may go into a little bit the
history a little bit more, but by 1840,
when the British invaded,
uh, with the Opium War, uh,
the British started to Dick,
the Chinese to opium and the
Chinese government said, no,
the British tried free
trade and invaded to,
to force China to accept a British opium,
which they got a India. Okay,
that's a separate story,
which we may or may not
have have time for. Oh.
But then so in a very
short period of time,
China goes from being one of the dominant
countries in the world to being sort
of, uh, the porn in the world that the,
that the British start colonizing it, the,
the German start colonizing it,
the Americans take advantage.
Everybody starts taking
advantage of China,
starts the colonization of China and
starts the dismembering of China.
And why did this happen is one of the
major issues in, in world history.
And there's many,
many different points of view on this.
There's 10 major theories or something.
Uh,
and in this class I just have
to unwind one thread, uh, uh,
one version of the story and
only one thread of that story.
And that's the relationship
between the population of China,
the wealth of China and
the poverty of China.
This particular thread about population
was obvious to Europeans visiting China,
even in the European Middle Ages.
And you know,
Marco Polo visited China in the 12
hundreds and he described China's
cultivation, how every little bit
of land was under very intense, uh,
cultivation already a popular snus that
the population was already incredibly
dense as viewed through European eyes of,
of,
of the same time and Indus Industry.
The people work very hard and we're,
whatever they did, they were very
productive at it. So, and he, you know,
they're the stories of Kubler con and all
that were from Marco Polo that he sort
of idolized China as this
incredibly rich, uh, but very,
very crowded place.
Adam Smith in the 17th century,
the guy who started modern economics
said China has long been one of the
richest,
most fertile,
best cultivated and most industrious and
most populous countries in the world.
So Adam Smith was aware of it and
all of these great scholars of,
of the, of the lady 17 hundreds were
looking around the world. Funny.
There was enough,
a seafaring us,
they could go around the world and
compare different things and try to figure
out what was the best system
for people to live under.
A few years after Adam Smith Maltus
writes and he quotes the information that
Europeans were getting were mostly from
Jesuit priests who had gone over to
China to try to convert the population.
And he quotes one a rather
well known a Jesuit priest.
Then China is code the richest and
most flourishing empire in the world.
But the priest goes on because
of Oprah overpopulation,
the people are the poorest
and most miserable of all.
And so right from way,
way back people that where they're trying
to was basically very rich country.
But because of the huge population,
the individual families were
often in abject poverty.
Well, if you looked at the,
at the emperor and the,
and the nobles,
of course they had enormous wealth.
These early observers were
certainly correct, uh,
about the population issue there.
So we have data from say 1750 and China
had 500 people per cultivated a square
kilometer.
At the same time.
Europe had about 70 people
for the square kilometer.
So China had to on the same farm land how
to support seven times as many people.
And of course numbers from 1750.
Uh,
don't take that as any kind of
an exact number up to today.
China has something like 20% of the
world's population because the one child
policy, the ratio was higher.
They had more than 20%. Uh,
but now it's down to about 20%
because India is still coming up.
A lot of the world is still coming up in
China. Population is still increasing,
but increasing at a,
at a rather slow rate.
It has now 20% of the world's population,
but only six to 7% of the arable land,
the farmable land in the world,
the amount of farm land per
person is 0.2 acres, uh,
per person 10 times less
than the United States has.
So there's a real problem,
uh, with China's population.
And the question is why,
why,
why did China's population press up
against the resources and riches of,
of the land?
So much more so than in,
say Europe for most of history.
Uh, China's, uh,
population does not
look terribly different.
Hang on. Anyway, you can, you can
see this, that in the Han dynasty,
which was the first unifying dynasty
of China, very much the same
time as the Roman empire,
it had a population of 50,
60 million.
Then according to this reconstruction
of China's history and all of these
reconstructions were very iffy.
Uh,
you notice population stays
stable for a thousand years.
Then during the Song Dynasty,
which is one of the very most important
dynasties and try very successful
population rises and then
it falls back down again.
The one which is the Mongol invasions.
This,
this decline that probably is very much
characterized by the Mongol invasions.
The particular dates here are dates
when we have censuses in the various
emperors took census as an in between.
You really don't know what's happening
and you're also not sure how complete
these censuses are. But anyway, the
Mongol invasion then stays constant.
And then some time in this period,
uh,
probably there's no census really.
They don't have any data between 1,417 50.
So this curve in here
is kind of guesswork,
but sometime in the 17 hundreds,
as in Europe,
the population takes off something
like this doesn't look wildly,
uh, in shape, in magnitude.
It's different, but in shape,
it doesn't look very
different than Europe. Uh,
the third,
uh,
in the Han dynasty 60 million
Chinese 1400 years later in 1,393,
they kind of 60 and a
half million of people,
and in between the population
went as low as 37 million.
And then as I said,
the Mongol invasions decimated
the population and then
just before the European
black death, but a decimation in the
same sense as the European black death.
And then it took a long time
per China's population, uh,
to come back up by the
beginning of the Ming Dynasty,
one of the also very flourishing
periods in Chinese history.
China had maybe 75 million people
up from up from 60 million,
and then it starts doubling in the
next 200 years. It doubles, uh,
and continues on up
as in Europe,
there were major epidemics in the 1640s,
uh,
there was some major epidemic
that we can like him to play,
but people really don't know
what kind of a of a disease.
It was an a Chinese scholar wrote in 1642,
the pestilence, you don't know
what the pestilence arose. Again,
on a large scale effecting eight or nine
of every 10 households in a household
of 10 or 20 people, all would be
afflicted and often all would die.
At first, the bodies were buried
in coffins and next in grasses.
But finally they were just left in the
places where they died in one big city in
1643,
there were few suits.
There was basically no signs
of human life in the streets.
Only the buzzing of flies broke
the silence. Those are quotes from,
from Chinese observers.
Very interesting.
It was at this time and in the 1640s,
that the Chinese having
experienced this massive disease,
developed a new theater, new medical
theory of disease and epidemic spaced on.
She knew all her cheat,
which is supposedly sort of the life
force that's involved in acupuncture and
everything.
And their view was that there was this
sort of non material substance force,
kind of like Phlogiston in the
west and it had to be in balance.
And when the CI on Heaven and Earth there
was CI and heaven and she on Earth got
disrupted,
uh,
then playing and then chaos broke out
on earth and people started dying of
various diseases. And of course, you know,
Americans have recently become wildly
infatuated with Chinese medicine and,
and the, the chief theory of
things and acupuncture. And uh,
we can talk a lot about that
privately if you wish. But, uh,
the point of that did not help the
Chinese at all. You can see the birth,
the medical statistics as again,
as far as we have them.
And up until recent times from
the practice of acupuncture,
you don't see any form of disease lessened
at all. And the only thing you see in,
in China,
and Japan also is a tremendous rise in
hepatitis because of the transmission
from the needles because they didn't
understand anything about sterilization.
Okay.
And then these plagues caused enormous
political changes just just as in Europe.
So the, the Ming Dynasty, for instance,
fell possibly as a result of the
depopulation and chaos of the,
of the plague.
And that allowed the Mongols to come in
and set up their own dynasty. I'm sorry,
the, uh, uh, the Manchu for Manchuria,
the Manchu to come in and
set up the Ching Dynasty.
And similarly, uh, to Europe, uh,
after one of these decimation
of the population, uh,
good land became available and people
moved into the good land and they had a,
a blossoming of, of, of
wealth and culture for the,
even for the peasants.
And it's a cycle not very different
than what morphous talked about,
balancing the relationship between the
number of people and the amount of land
available
throughout this whole period.
A life expectancy was very poor.
Uh,
we have scattered statistics.
So a village in the 1790s showed that
one third of male children died in their
first year of life and half of them
died before they were, they were 20.
And the female situation was comparable,
but probably worse because of infanticide.
So they're probably counting only
those that got through the period of
infanticide. Life expectancy was 32, uh,
in this particular village,
and only 4% of the
population lived past 65.
And again, it's not terribly different
than what we saw in the statistic. The,
the graph for CIS Alpine goal.
We're about a third of the of the
women are dead before they start their
reproductive life.
But when the main came to power, uh, um,
there was still land, uh, unoccupied
land available. As Martha said,
the best land was already
used for agriculture, but
there was less good land, uh,
still available. And under
the main, the population grew.
We're talking 16 hundreds into
17 hundreds. Uh, the main, uh,
uh, I'm sorry, the ends
and the 1650 or so. Um,
and the population grew,
what the people do,
they moved onto the marginal land and
that meant higher into the mountains on
steeper trying to farm on steeper slopes.
They cleared forested areas,
they moved into dry areas.
And the result of all this was enormous
soil erosion that especially the
mountain sides and the dry areas,
the productivity dropped because
this land is just not good.
And the erosion, the forest couldn't hold
the water anymore. The period of China,
China has always had floods.
It's a big part of Chinese history,
but these really massive,
massive uncontrollable floods date
from this period where the people,
the population increased and people
started going into areas where, uh,
it's ecologically very unstable,
cutting down the forests.
And then when it rains you
get these enormous floods.
And also the floods, not
only uh, uh, there was the,
but they devastated the
agriculture in the low lands.
So you not only had a poorer agriculture
per capita in the high lands,
but you also reduce the per capita
of farming in the low lands.
Again, population growth, uh,
can, can make it difficult
for everybody. So again, like,
like Europe, like Africa, uh,
American foods when they were discovered
when into China, because they, as I said,
have something like twice to kill caloric
content of, of anything except rice.
If you can grow rice, rice is as good
as potatoes are just about as as good.
And so China picked up a sweet potatoes,
especially peanuts, especially,
uh, some white potatoes and
they doubled food production.
And guess what happened? The
population doubled. So again,
the introduction of these foods and the
tremendous improvement in agriculture
didn't help, uh, the per capita eating
the per capita amount of food, uh,
for individuals.
And the,
during the same period as
people increased, uh, one
farmer could grow more land,
but the people that could eat
needed more land for themselves.
So they moved again out.
And the land under cultivation
increased by a factor of 4.5 times.
But, but again, uh, during this sort
of second round of population growth,
one is after the,
uh,
when the main takeover in one is
after American foods are introduced.
Um, the erosion becomes extreme
and it's so extreme that by 1978,
about one,
uh,
one third of all arable land in China
had to be abandoned because of erosion.
So it's an, it's an enormous
problem in, in China.
And so this is really trying
to experience small cysts,
what I call my office with
a vengeance. So this is, um,
the, uh, cultivated only
still didn't find it.
Oh, there it is. There
it is. Okay. So, uh,
this is cultivated land
and you can see that here.
1700 sold.
Basically,
American foods come in and you can plant
stuff everywhere and the amount of land
under cultivation goes up like
crazy. Some of this decline is, is,
is very recent as industrialization,
cities growing and some
of it is you erosion.
So the land thing looks like an
enormous increase in the amount of land
available for farming.
But here is the per capita amount of land,
the cultivated land,
heck terrace per capita where this is,
this is simple hectares. And, uh, it, it,
it grows then it,
then it crashes probably again to do
with the Mongol invasions are just fewer
people. Uh, I'm sorry, I've gone
probably have this backwards rises here.
The land per, uh, per capita because
you just get rid of the people.
And then in the modern population growth,
the land per capita just just
crashes down and now it's,
this is 0.2 hectares.
Now we're 0.1 hectare per person,
which is like a quarter of an acre,
very small amount of land per person.
And of course the Chinese realize
this as well as anybody. And uh,
it was in a matter of official concern
during the Ming and the Ching dynasties.
And in 1790 just before Malthus wrote
a Chinese scholar and high government
official a hung a young g,
he started warning the Chinese about the
difficulties that unchecked population
growth would cause as an outrage.
Chinese productive capacity.
That's the way he phrased it.
So it's clear that the original
understanding of of China,
that its population was pressing really
severely against it. It's resources, uh,
was accurate,
but it still doesn't explain why was it
in China that you got these incredibly
dense populations.
Why didn't that happen elsewhere
saying China or England.
And so what, what jumps to your mind?
Probably at a very high fertility.
They had no in,
in,
in England we talked about the late
marriage system and everything,
which kept fertility down on Americans
generally have the image in western
history only have the image of uh,
the Chinese, uh, reproduce, uh,
have a lot of children all the time.
It's like your grandparents or something.
So in this makes good sense.
In the Chinese culture,
the principal goal of life was to produce
sons as you've heard over and over
again. And uh, this origin of
ancestor worship I think is,
as you just said, goes back at least
the second and third millennium BC.
So 5,000 years. What Ching said is, is,
is the scholarly number.
And uh,
they did all kinds of things to get us
on adoption was very, very calm, calm.
And you'll read about that in the
reading if you haven't already.
James Lee talks about very
high rates of adoption.
People who didn't have a
son would get an adoption.
And the filial piety that
they had a confusion system,
which I'll talk about in a
moment where you know, the older,
the younger brothers for instance,
had to pay absolute obedience to the
older brothers and they all had to pay up
through the obedience to the father.
So if a younger brother had a son and
the older brother didn't do younger
brother had to give that son, uh, to
the older brother, my modern times,
that was the same situation and chinks
on the, of course, that confusion,
that strict Confucian thing
doesn't exist anymore.
But in the old days it would
always be the younger sons,
no matter what the biological story was.
It would always be the younger sons
that did not have, uh, a male children.
And so in China, everyone
was expected to marry, uh,
and, and, uh, they married very young
in order to secure a bride. Because,
as I mentioned to you, I
think with respect to the
little sex selective abortion,
traditionally China has always done
away with 10 to 25% of its females.
So there was always, not always,
but as much as we have data, um,
and so there's always been an excess
of males and, and a lot of, you know,
they can't get married.
Uh,
so they did all kinds of things
to secure a bride for, for a son.
And that included getting patrolled very,
very young and,
and starting reproduction
as soon as puberty allowed.
Um,
and it was made worse by the fact that
it was quite acceptable for males to take
second wise or third wives or
fourth wives down into concubines.
And every time one male had more than
one wife than some other nail and got no
wife at all.
Okay.
So let's look, so one of the
possibilities is the obvious one is,
is trying to have very high fertility
and we'll see if that's true.
So here's a bunch of of data.
And what this is,
is the age of,
of the woman and they don't have much
reproduction beyond age 40 in the sample
of though modernly we would have the age
of the woman and what her rate is per
uh, I guess per thousand
uh, uh, uh, women.
And you can see,
so women start out at age 20 with a very
high rate and all these curves with a
high rate of reproduction, it either
goes down a little bit by age 25 or,
or sometimes in some places it
increases a little bit by age 25.
And then as a woman gets older,
a fertility drops off.
There's fewer and fewer children per
year at 40 year olds just have fewer
children than 20 or 25 year olds.
That's a very obvious kind of thing.
Now these are two different
sets of pop thing.
This is date their data from one area of
the world data from another area of the
world. One area is cha, all of the data,
China with one line from Japan.
And the other set of data is a Europe,
various European countries.
And guess which is which
some hands,
the big difference and fertility.
Yeah.
You think John is the one at the bottom?
That's right. That's the lead
article. So in the lecture where one,
one lecture behind us,
as you've probably realized already,
and so the reading that you
should do tonight actually
gave away the answer. Yes.
This is the European population.
This is the Chinese population so that
the Chinese once married within marriage
and both places extra marital fertility
is not a big deal. So this is,
you can take this as general repression.
But within marriage,
the Europeans had a much higher rate of
child bearing than the Chinese didn't.
In fact,
it's almost a factor of two
from 200 to 300 to 400 to 500,
that it was a lot. Uh, uh, the Europeans,
once married one's having access to,
to sex really had children
uncontrollably as, as, as one says,
where's the Chinese were doing
something, uh, to control, uh,
their, their births. And that was
a shocker when this data came out.
And it's fairly recent data because the
presumption from at least small offices
time was that, you know, the
Chinese just reproduced like,
like like flies or something and that the
Europeans had this wonderful restraint
and it turns out that's just the
opposite of what is what is true.
And it's,
and it's very surprising given the
cultural emphasis on reproduction by the
Chinese. So one of the big
issues now under discussion is
whether this is a sign that the Chinese
were consciously doing some kind of
birth control.
They were consciously trying to limit
their families or whether it was one of
these cultural things where the culture
in some sense stumbles onto a practice
and it makes that cultural successful
even though the people have no idea what
the purpose of of it is.
It may just be as sort of
an as an artifact of culture
and they will think the,
the, the population will think
this is due to their, uh,
their following God's rules
or the proper decorum or,
or various cultural reasons.
They will give a cultural reasons why
they have few children and not understand
that that's what makes
the whole society survive.
And James Lee, who is, uh, definitely the,
the world's foremost
demographer of China are,
he has no doubt, even though the data
is not as solid as one would like,
here's no doubt that it was
infrequent sexual activity, uh,
that led to the low of birth
rate as a cultural thing,
not as a conscious way of,
of, of, of reducing, uh,
fertility. And he describes
a story where, uh,
a young couple gets
married and they're in the,
what we perceive as the height of,
of sexual desire and what their sleeping
arrangements are. They have, uh,
there's a double decker bed and the two,
there's married,
the young married couple of sleeps above
and the grandmother is in the bed below
and the grandmother has it, carries
her cane to bed and we never upstairs,
she started hears things starting to
go on, Bang, Bang, Bang, cut it out.
And so that kind of thing that the
old people didn't go along with this.
And the reason for this, I mean
as, as as the Chinese would see it,
is that the confusion Etha ethic,
they don't have, it's not right.
It's not a religious thing
and all. There's no, no
sense of a deity or anything,
anything supernatural going
on. But personal relationships
are what's important.
The sub and their set of unequal,
a personal relationship,
a subject has to give absolute
deference to the ruler is the emperor.
A children have to give absolute
deference to the parents and to elders.
Women have to give absolute deference
first to her brothers and that her
husband's women to men.
Uh,
younger brothers have to give absolute
deference to their older brothers and of
these, the only relationship that's
equal his friend, friend relationship.
That's the fifth relationship.
So you can be buddies with your friend,
but you must be superior to wife.
New Wife must be inferior to you.
And so you cannot be friends with them.
Love or passion between the married
couple. Not only didn't happen,
it was not approved of. It was like be
you're being bad. If you love your wife,
if you have passion for why
that an a not a good thing.
And so husband and wife did not relate
to each other as lovers or even as
friends. And there's a very
famous Chinese story, uh,
where a young man had been married some
years is walking with a friend with a
mail from another male friend with
whom he can be fun and converse.
And he's bemoaning his fate that
here he loves his wife. So extremely,
but he can't have a, uh, he can't
express his love for her to her.
He can't have walks in the moonlight
like he's having with his male friend.
He can't have this kind of a chat with
her because that is against the morality
and ethics, uh, of the, of the system. So,
uh,
these cultural things,
which I think no Chinese of
the time would describe as, oh,
that's the way we keep our population
down or what is the explanation for this
rather than, uh, some kind of, uh, uh,
of conscious effort.
Also,
another factor that is not a conscious
sort of thing is the Chinese married
younger than Europeans. So when
you do an age adjusted thing by 20,
they had been married for several years
and is what's called the boredom factor
going on now. And no matter
what age, couple of Marriott,
they have sex a lot in the beginning.
And so they,
if they're not protecting themselves,
they have a,
a high birth rate and then it falls down.
And some fraction of this difference
here may just be to due to the age of
marriage.
Yeah.
Yeah. So we're going to get to that. Uh,
actually we may not get to it till
next time, but that's still, again,
we're pushing out. We still haven't
explained why the population, uh,
is more dense and it's getting time.
Let me just finish saying something
about this. 10 to 25%, uh,
getting rid of the females,
which again would reduce the population,
would lead you to not think there
was a such a density, uh, in the,
in the 17th century. Uh, again, this
is from Jesuit missionaries to China,
uh, reporting back to Europe. They were
horrified to find that in Beijing alone,
taking it at the time,
several thousand babies,
almost exclusively females were thrown
into the streets like refuse to be
collected each morning by carriers who
dumped them into huge pits outside the
city.
And it sounds very much like,
like Europe of of a similar time.
And what's interesting is that right
now China is approaching pretty much the
same female with their
sex selective in fancy,
pretty much the same female deficits
that's been as far as we can tell,
the traditional, uh, level of it.
But now there's all this moaning
and groaning about, you know,
all these unmarried males and how it will
utterly disrupt Chinese society. And,
and you know, it's a horrible
sort of thing. And also,
I think I mentioned this before, as you've
seen in Europe, we're rather than, uh,
10 to 25% of the males not being able to
get married because of Devs, a females,
40, 50, 60% of the males did
not get married in Europe.
I showed you the graphs of that
when we discuss, uh, Europe.
So the Chinese, uh, system, uh,
fertility system, which, which,
uh, keeps their population manageable,
not, it's not small, but manageable,
uh, is, uh, moderately
early, not extremely early,
moderately early, a nearly universal
marriage of surviving females. Uh,
in 1998 for the prince,
only 1% of Chinese women
were unmarried by age 30,
whereas in the West in that year,
15% are unmarried, 15 times as much,
uh,
even by age 14 in the West.
And so the European system was that only
about half of everybody got married.
Uh, but once, uh, once married,
they had births at about twice
the rate of Chinese. In Chinese,
all the women got married,
but within marriage they
had a low rate of fertility.
So you have to cut your
fertility down by half,
either by the European thing of,
of less than complete marriage or by the
Chinese thing of less than complete a
fertility. So it looks like, uh, that, uh,
pop fertility there. The total fertility
rates should be more or less the same,
the same between China and,
and Europe,
but by essentially opposite
kinds of fertility systems.
And we'll see. I'm sorry. Next
time we'll continue and we'll see.
What is one of the theories for why
China got into the, the difficulties.
It was not just uncontrolled reproduction.